The reason you're dissatisfied is
because you want things you don't have.
And you are unhappy with the trades that
you've made, but you want to keep the
things you got from making those trades
and then also retrade whatever it is
that you gave to get what you've got for
something else without accepting the
downsides and trades of getting that
thing. And so I was having this
conversation with, you know, a friend of
mine who's kind of in this his dating
period of life trying to figure out, you
know, who's going to marry and and
whatnot. And he sends me these very
long, you know, voice notes and and text
messages about how it's like, should I,
you know, should I have a stay-at-home
mom type wife, a wife who's like, you
know, career oriented or should I try
and have somebody who would work with
me? And he's just going through this
this whole, you know, rigomeroll. And
he's he struggled with this for a while.
And fundamentally it comes down to this
which is that he wants everything. And
I'm not just saying this about him. I'm
saying this about us, about all of us,
right? It's like we want it all. And one
of the the key, you know, formulas for
getting dissatisfied with life is
wanting everything with limited
resources in terms of time, energy,
effort, life, uh, in order to get them.
And so I see this key thing, myself
included here, that I'll do sometimes
where I'll get something that I want and
then I'll look at something else that's
a different path and be like, I want
that, too. But we used up the same
resource to get it, right? It's like if
you have gas in the car and you're like,
well, I've got one tank worth of gas.
You're like, I want to get to Toledo.
And then you get to Toledo and you're
like, I actually really want to get to,
you
know, Orange County. Well, all of a
sudden you're like, I used up my tank of
gas. It's like, well, I want to go to
Orange County, too. It's like, well,
you're in Toledo. You know what I mean?
Like, you made that call. And so, it's
interesting is that we regret the lives
we have because of paths not
taken without taking into consideration
the trades we made then. And so one of
the things that I that I feel like I've
been practicing a lot has been this this
effort of trying
to play it out more, which is like,
okay, well, let's say that we went to
Orange County, not Toledo. Well, I might
be thinking in Orange County like, man,
Toledo's got all these things that are
going on there and they've got these
great sites and they've got, you know,
more modest people and and and and and
right. And so it's like all paths have
things that you don't currently have.
But the other part is like, okay, well,
whatever path I choose not to play out
also has costs. And so we have the
perceived benefits of this other path
which might not be as good as we think
they are, right? And then we have these
unknown costs which might be
significantly worse than they are. And
so I was talking to him, you know, about
about this and I was like, well, listen,
man. Like all three of these paths are
fine. And I've seen really successful
people who are in all three of these,
you know, paths like stay-at-home
situation, parallel situation, aligned
or combined situation. All three work,
right? But like wanting the the benefits
of all three is what gets us in trouble,
right? I think I saw Esther Peral make
this clip where she was like the
problems that we have isn't that like
people are worse, it's just that our
expectations are higher. It's like we
expect our spouse to be
uh professional, you know, a
professional business person, to be an
intellectual sparring partner.
Um, uh, to be intellectual sparring
partner, to be your, you know, if it's a
guy, it's like your your maid and your
housekeeper, also the mother and great
parent, you know, for your kids. Um,
also somebody who's like interested in
the same hobbies as you, and also your
passionate lover. It's like it's trying
to cram 10 10 humans into one, right?
Like you make trades, right? There are
things that you're going to get and
there's things that you're going to
trade. And you know, we get we get
dissatisfied when we just make trades.
And I see this like kind of like for us
as individuals that there's kind of
these stages you go through. Like in the
beginning, you just blame everyone else
for why you don't have what you want,
right? That's like stage one. Stage two,
you learn how to get stuff. So now you
get something that you want, but you're
like,
man, I want I want that other path,
right? I want the benefits of that
without the cost of that. But in my
mind, I'm going to imagine getting both
my current life and that life and then
I'm just going to be dissatisfied since
I don't have both. And I heard this
really interesting quote, which I love.
Not wanting something is as good as
having
it. Not wanting it is as good as having
it. And I think about this trade all the
way up, right? It's like when we die cuz
people are always like, you know, I
really, you know, they get to the end of
their life and then they have these
quote regrets. They look back and they
try and like quote give advice, but like
I actually don't take as much credence
in that. And I'll explain why. It's not
like I don't, you know, respect old
people. It's more a human thing than an
old person thing. just that when we die
wanting another life or a different
life, it really just comes down to I
wish I had the benefits of another life
while also maintaining the benefits of
my own. And if someone's a little bit
more astute, they'd say, well, I would
trade the benefits of that life that's
unknown for the life that uh for the
benefits of the life that I have, but it
still has kind of contained within it.
You know, all these are known. So,
you're still trading no you're trading
novelty, right? Which makes sense. But
it doesn't also doesn't actually inform
decision-m in a good way. And so what
ends up happening is we create this
equation, right? Like life becomes
miserable when you get when you want
everything but have limited resources to
get it. Which then you say I will be
dissatisfied unless I get everything.
And by the way, everything will change.
The thing I want I'll change it as soon
as I get it. I'll change it so that I
can maintain dissatisfaction. Think
about how wild this is.
Like we proclaim that unless I get
everything an impossible thing, I will
be
dissatisfied. So you might as well just
say I choose to be
dissatisfied. That is what I I demand
this. Of course, the universe doesn't
care. You're not going to get any of
that stuff. Back to my friend, a lot of
this I think comes down to commitment
and expectations. When Leila and I
decided to get married, you know, we uh
we actually got married pretty fast and
then decided to like look at marriage
stuff right afterwards. But one of the
things that we looked at was like what
are the commonalities between marriages
that last? And it's not actually what
you think, but I narrowed it into two
two kind of buckets here. And I think
this goes for any endeavor, not just
marriage, but like big life
choices. High
commitment, low
expectations. That's the pairing. If you
think about commitment as the
elimination of alternatives, well then
that makes sense that if you eliminate
all alternatives that you
will that by default you will stay
you'll stay on the path that you're
currently on whether it's marriage,
whether it's business. So it's you just
eliminate all alternatives. It's another
shot you're committed and then low
expectations which is like okay you're
committed here. Maybe you don't get
married but then you can either change
reality or or lower expectations. So
then you just have low expectations and
you're not going anywhere. And the thing
is is that if you have low expectations
and you're not going anywhere, then
reality is likely higher than your
expectations, which ends up meaning that
you're above expectations for the m for
the rest of your life. And so that has
always been my like whenever I feel like
this creep of dissatisfaction or wanting
more or things like that or wanting
different. And to be clear, I this is
not be sick. I figured out life here
just sharing more just sharing a thought
that I was thinking about for myself
too. High expectation, low commitment.
Cuz I played out the other way for him,
you know, in particular. I was like, if
you were in a in a town of 500 people
and you were of marriage age, you'd have
a pick of like 25 girls, right? And
you'd be like, "Ah, the one I don't
hate." Right? Like you'd be like, "All
right, there we go." You know? And
people have been doing that for much
longer than they've been doing unlimited
swipes. And so, like, we just have this
very
odd perspective on reality, which is
that we want all of the upside and none
of the downside. We want a perfect life
and demand that we have one and then are
dissatisfied when our lives are not
perfect. We want all the upside like we
want to trade. We want we want all the
good stuff. It's like I want the I I'll
play this out. So it's
like I want the benefit of having uh a
really short wife who's itty bitty, you
know, whatever. And I also want a girl
that's, you know, 61 and can like mother
linebackers.
Well, I want both. You got to pick one,
but I want both. Okay, be dissatisfied
or and just never choose, right? Like,
like this is actually really
really stay stuck because they can't
decide. They're literally unwilling to
make they'll literally just stay there.
They just stay undecided and somehow
expect to get more information about an
apparent contradiction.
like you expect that you're going to get
more information. Like this is the
choice. You have to make it. And if you
don't make the choice, you don't get the
benefits of either. And that's what's
wild. And so
like I think about this a fair amount
because there's just so many choices
that we have to make, right, throughout
life where like some doors are are
reversible, right? But the big doors in
life are irreversible. It's hard to go
back, right? Like you can't become 20
years old again. You can't marry another
person again. You can't pick another
business. I mean, you can you can get
divorced from your business. It's just
painful. There's wind down periods. You
know who you know just it just it's p
you know who who comes you know who
comes with you to your to your new
business who doesn't like it's a whole
mess, right? So think you can get
divorced from your marriage, right? You
can do that but it's it's tough, right?
And so we have these doors that we we
can really only go through one time and
people will just stand at the precipice
of the door and just wait their entire
lives never getting what's on the other
side of either door or either path. And
so I think like a
prized trait is the ability to both make
decisions and to make good decisions.
And I'll give the third and this is me
mostly talking to myself as you can see
being happy with our decisions which I
think is a significantly underrated
skill. Like first you have to learn how
to decide right if you don't make
decisions you do nothing. Then you have
to learn how to decide well so that your
decisions work
out. You get more of what you want. And
then number three is that you have to
not change what you said you wanted from
the decision that you made and or just
be satisfied with whatever you get on
the other side of that decision with the
ultimate obviously just being that you
didn't want anything to begin with which
is we can all become Buddhist monks
until that day comes. I would say that
it's been helpful for me to just simply
recognize the trades that I made and say
yes I am okay with this trade and then
whenever I think about an alternative
path just reminding myself well there
would be cost on that path and the
upside of that path is probably not as
good as I think it is and so me just
being real with you like I've been kind
of about as happy or unhappy as I am now
for like a pretty long time and I like
this is me just being really real I I
don't think I think if I were to play
out three different lifetimes for me in
different countries and and different
upbringings, the whole thing, like I
think I'd probably be about as happy or
unhappy as I am
now. Like I'm just being real. Like I
just as much as I like and that actually
just actually thinking that has
dramatically decreased
my anxiety around some stuff like my
worries. It's just like wow, I'd
probably be about as happy as I am now.
I'd have different variables, but it
would probably equate to where I'm at.
So, I gave the tall girl, short girl for
a girl example. It's like maybe it's
like a richer guy, a poorer guy. I don't
know. I don't know what the example
would be. Maybe it's a richer guy.
Sorry, a taller guy and a shorter guy
for girls. I don't know. But the idea is
like fundamentally like there's just
going to be trades that you're going to
make and everyone might think, "Oh, no.
I would definitely want the rich guy."
Well, let's play it out. Let's actually
play it out. Look at the wives of rich
dudes. Are they happy? Not
always. Look at the wives of poor dudes.
Are they happy? Not always. Which
basically just means humans will human.
We will be
dissatisfied independent of our
circumstance. And that honestly at the
end of the day like we are the
problem. Like we are the problem. Like
we think there's something like we are
the problem.
And so that's actually um my little like
refrain that I have for myself whenever
I have this little creeping
dissatisfaction spider that that creeps
up my neck. I just hear like you are the
problem. You are the
problem. And then I think okay I am the
problem. What expectations do I have
that I set arbitrarily for myself that I
deemed dissatisfactory when the world
did not meet them?
I'm like, "Oh, okay. Well, if I just
remove that, it's as good as having it."
Great. Good to
know. So, anyways, love you all. Just a
little morning thoughts. It's uh 5:40ish
here at the office. We're really excited
for the book launch. It's going to be
epic. I've been basically preparing for
two years for this. Um, basically is a
the incorrect word. I have been
preparing for two years for this. Um,
and so, uh, I'm excited to finally show
you what I've been working on this whole
time. It's going to be really sweet. And
I had to somehow outdo last time, which
was, uh, awesome. So, it's like, how do
I, how do I do better than that? Come
and you will see. Uh, otherwise, be
awesome. I'll catch you guys soon. Bye.